hey what is up everybody it's animak
here for anime uproar and today i will
be breaking down the latest shocking
chapter in the mha manga the hero killer
stain ambushes and confronts all might
at knife point or i guess i should say
sword point but either way it was crazy
oh and if that wasn't enough stain has
top secret information about the
villains from tartarus there is a lot to
talk about so let's get into it you guys
know the drill if you enjoy our boku no
hero videos and you want to see more in
the future leave a quick like and
comment it only takes a second but it
helps a lot with the youtube algorithm
and if you're new to the channel or
maybe you watch the channel regularly
but you just haven't taken the time to
subscribe yet it would really help
support the channel if you would take
the time to subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you can also hit me up on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
finally this video will of course
contain boku rohiro manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned now even though the previous
chapter was largely an optimistic one
the final panel showed a somber looking
almighty standing out in the rain the
latest chapter picks up with all might
driving alone through that same raid he
is going to check on some of those
anti-hero protesters who are refusing to
evacuate into a shelter presumably these
are the people who stopped trusting the
heroes and who decided to take their
safety into their own hands by forming
various civilian militias these guys
have no interest in leaving their homes
and moving into shelters controlled by
the heroes since they don't believe that
the heroes have what it takes to keep
them safe
with that said heroes like all might
still feel responsible for protecting
everyone including these people and
because they refused to evacuate they
are more vulnerable than anyone else to
villain attacks as he's driving all
might is thinking about deku about how
he made a promise to encode that he
would protect deku and yet deku decided
to go off on his own and leave all might
behind i mean he even left that freaking
bento box which was not cool and then
deku almost got himself killed before
his classmates came to his rescue and of
course all might feels terrible because
he wasn't there to help him this is
something that weighs heavily on all
might's shoulders especially since he
knows that even if he was there he
probably wouldn't have been able to do
much against the villain in his current
physical state the small might form as
we call it there isn't much that all
might can do even if he wanted to
eventually all might finds himself in
that same square where deku had faced
the villain dictator and then after that
his own classmates all might sees deku's
disheveled mask on the ground and so he
picks up the mask and looks upon the
large statue of all might that is
located in the square the statue that
now has a sign over it that reads i am
not here almight again thinks about the
fact that he couldn't even protect his
own student deku and he says to the
statue and also to himself that he
almight is just dragging everyone down
this is again where those unrealistic
standards that i mentioned many times
before come into play in the past
almight was the symbol of peace the
symbol of the hero society itself as
long as all might was around everyone
was fine because they knew that this
incredibly strong hero was always
watching and he would do anything to
protect the people all might had set
such an insanely high standard for
heroes that people started relying on
them too much they relied on heroes to
solve all of their problems heroes
became celebrities and many of the
heroes became more interested in money
and fame than actual heroics after all
if all might is always there to save the
day when things get really bad then do
other heroes really need to worry about
the danger and sacrifice aspect of being
a hero all might will take care of all
the real problems while other lesser
known heroes can just focus on money and
fame obviously this was not the mindset
of every hero but as we saw in the
previous arc many heroes were fair
weather heroes and when things got bad
they bailed once all might could no
longer live up to those impossible
standards that he himself had set the
hero society collapsed pretty quickly
and all might is now left wondering
whether he is partially to blame for all
of it but almight's train of thought is
soon interrupted by a sword-wielding
maniac who holds a blade up to his face
that maniac is none other than the hero
killer stain and it seems that he heard
toshinori's previous comment about all
might dragging people down this comment
straight up triggered stain and with a
crazy look in his eyes he demands that
this skinny blonde man in front of him
take back what he said about all might
stain of course doesn't realize that he
is speaking to all might himself or at
least that's what stain wants us to
believe as i said toshinoriagi is
currently in his small mite form and
this is a form that stain doesn't
necessarily recognize stain seems to
think that this man is just some random
dude insulting the greatest hero of all
time and he refuses to stand by and
allow that to happen toshinori explains
that a lot has changed since stain had
gone to prison and he reveals that he is
in fact almight stain is shocked by this
and he refuses to believe it at first
but toshinori demonstrates that he is
almight by briefly transforming back
into his talmide form and yet stain
still refuses to believe that this thin
frail man is the larger than life hero
whom he respects so much stain proclaims
that this square where all might statue
stands is sacred ground built to honor
true heroes so how dare this weak fake
try to impersonate the greatest hero and
toshinori actually agrees that he is a
fake in a way he spent his entire life
trying to make a difference and trying
to help those who were powerless but in
the end he himself ended up powerless he
couldn't even protect his own student
despite making a promise to his mother
not to mention the fact that he couldn't
stop the collapse of the entire hero
society all might laments the fact that
he keeps getting further and further
away from the hero he once was but stain
refuses to listen stain seems to be on
the verge of having a mental breakdown
just listening to all might sounding so
hopeless and defeated and this kind of
reminds me of deku deku would probably
be just as shocked as staying if he
heard his idol talking this way which is
interesting in a way deku and stain are
two very different people and yet they
do share some similar ideals and at the
end of the day they are both all might
fanboys stain then grabs almight but he
doesn't grab him in a violent or
threatening way he grabs him in order to
show him a lone woman walking up to the
almighty statue the woman uses her quirk
to climb the statue and take down the
sign which says i am not here stain
explains that every single day this
woman comes here to clean the statue
from any vandalism conducted by the
anti-hero protesters even though this is
a dangerous task this area is not safe
anymore and those who keep vandalizing
the statue could attack her at any
moment the woman still risks her life
every day to defend the legacy of all
might toshinori is surprised by this he
doesn't know why this woman would bother
risking her life for some statue but
stane explains that she is the last
person all might had saved back during
the kamino incident she had been stuck
under some rubble and she would have
died if all might hadn't defeated all
for one in time for her to be rescued as
toshinori looks on in stunned silence
stain goes into a crazed rant about how
all might always kept a smile on his
face and always protected the people
this had nothing to do with his quirk
the man known as almight had unwavering
determination and dedicated his entire
life to preserve peace stain says that
as he is now toshinori can't even hold a
candle to all might but it's not over
yet that woman who cleans the statue
every day is proof that the cinders
which all might left behind continued to
burn within those who followed in his
footsteps these cinders are now forming
into a great fire as all of class 1a
unites under the same banner that all
might had once raised and that flame
must not be allowed to die they must
stoke it no matter how difficult the
situation becomes this speech is
actually pretty nuts when you think
about it the crazed villain known as
stain a man who has murdered dozens of
heroes is basically giving almight a pep
talk and reminding him that deku and
class 1a are now carrying the torch that
he had passed to them stain the hero
killer is praising the virtues of the
heroes and telling all might not to give
up this is not the kind of conversation
that toshita was expecting to have today
or any other day as he continues to look
at that woman who is cleaning the statue
toshinori sheds a tear stain turns to
walk away and as he leaves he tells
toshinori that a hero exists for the
sake of others and while he still
doesn't want to admit that this man is
really almight he tells him that if he
is a true hero then he will use the
information that stain had gathered from
tartarus we then see that stain left a
piece of paper on the ground a piece of
paper that he wants toshinori to read
stain then invites all might to one day
come and end him the villain who had
murdered 40 heroes it's almost like
stain is trying to encourage almight by
saying that once the villain crisis is
over and japan is saved he can come and
settle the score with him as well the
final words that come out of stain's
mouth are everything is for the sake of
a just society and as the rain finally
stops all might tears continue to flow
down his cheeks and that is how the
chapter ends wow what an unexpected
emotional moment a depressed and
powerless almighty getting a
motivational speech from a villain who
killed dozens of heroes and no matter
what you think of stain the man was
spitting and the interesting thing about
staying here is that he seems to be
partially in denial that his hero
almighty is now this weak and sad man
known as toshinoriagi and yet another
part of staying clearly knows that this
is almight if he didn't believe that
this was him what would be the point of
that motivational speech what would be
the point of leaving this random man
that note stain knows that this is all
might even if he doesn't want to admit
it and that makes this whole situation
even more emotional and impactful stain
wants toshinori to keep struggling and
pushing forward so that he can once
again live up to the legacy of all might
and then we have that note as of the end
of the chapter we have no idea what the
note says all we know is that stain got
some valuable information from tartarus
and that he wants the heroes to have it
but what could that information be is it
about a traitor who made the prison
break possible is it about the prisoners
who escaped and their quirks is it
something else entirely man stain is
such a fascinating characters and one of
my favorite characters in the entire
story i loved seeing this confrontation
and i really hope that we get to see
more of staying because he is just so
interesting i mean he's clearly not a
good person and clearly he does horrible
things and yet he does have some ideals
that we can totally relate to and he
even shares some of the same ideals as
our heroes deku and all might obviously
stain also has other warped ideals that
the heroes don't share but still it's so
interesting to think about stain's role
in the story going forward ever since
the tartarus prison break i've been
predicting that stain will fight on the
side of the heroes against the villains
and this is our first hint that he is
helping the heroes he just passed on
some valuable intel about the villains
to all might and i can't wait to find
out more about that note let me know
what you guys think how awesome is
staying as a character and what secret
information did he just pass on to all
might will stain play an important role
in the looming final showdown against
the villains will he and deku start a
new all might fan club when this is all
over don't forget to share your feedback
down in the comments below i always love
hearing from you if you enjoy our boku
no hero videos and you want to see more
you know what to do just leave a quick
like it only takes a second but it helps
a lot and if you're new to anime uproar
or maybe you watch our videos but you
just haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet do me a favor and make this the
video that you subscribe and hit that
notification bell to turn on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting the bell and then selecting that
option that says all if you don't do
that you're still gonna miss a ton of
our videos even if you are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter and instagram at
anime uproar i want to give a quick
thank you to all of our anime uproar
patrons who make videos like this one
possible special thank you to alpha
sigma he is an absolute mad lad and
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans including ingrata pate heffa
algital hinokamien water the toasted chi
the spike dylan isidore spidey life
tinel tungsten tarkis big buddhist and
monkey d quilly finally thank you to all
of our pro hero tier patrons including
the one and only gilgamesh the red
haired raven angel crews ratheora very
gucci alicia akhter bonnie parks joanne
garcia ted no ted fatboy games corey
mcgowan and soul ray slice and dice if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
so
[Music]
you